as long as man has told stories there
has been folklore tall tales and in the
Modern Age urban legends more recently
the Advent of the internet has resulted
in an explosion of stories often
referred to as Creepy Pasta the most
well-known creepy pastas such as Slender
Man Jeff the Killer and the Russian
sleep experiment were usually fictional
stories originally created by Anonymous
internet users using a pseudonim but the
lore is often times built upon by the
internet Community usually the result is
that the original author loses control
of his or her creation and that seems to
be what happens in 2012 in the case of
smiley usually that only happens when
the story is good to begin with but
Smiley has proven that there are
exceptions to learn how YouTubers made a
horror movie so controversial that it
had to be wiped off the face of the
internet and how the legacy of smiley
still persists today stick around to the
end of this video